that knew my adventures with Superman
show is getting crazy hype at the moment
and it's kind of easy to see why anime
Superman with fun X-Men evolution Vibes
it's been in production for a while now
and there was a point when things were
really unsure when HBO was canceling
shows left and right but thankfully this
survived albeit with an unfortunate suit
downgrade but hey season two is already
on the way so we're good there the
showroom is a guy called Jake Wyatt
who's a proper anime nerd like you look
at his Twitter feed and the dudes
gushing about Dragon Ball chainsaw man
Evangelion all the classics and it's so
clear to see in this Show's DNA I mean
these robots in episode 2 are straight
out of Ava and Lois design might as well
just be Abby from great Pretender the
animations being done by Studio mirror
of Avatar and core of Fame which is kind
of neat it's not really shown anything
of that level yet but it's had its
moments and it sure does look nice I'm
super excited no pun intended to see
where this one goes have you watched it
yet let me know in the comments what you
thought